[Musique]
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
l'humoriste jarry semble avoir tapé dans
l'oeil de la direction de tf1 après
avoir été mis à l'honneur comme
participant dans de nombreuses émissions
comme à singer ou vaitape lui avoir
confié la présentation en prime de
l'émission game of talend c'est
aujourd'hui côté fiction qu'on le
retrouve sur la première chaîne s'est
reprise il n'est pas seulement l'acteur
principal de ce téléfilm inédit intitulé
à tes côtés il en est aussi le héros
dans le scénario de cet unitaire est
inspiré de sa vraie vie un garçon qui
aime les autres garçons comme son oncle
en tenez un effet un drame et 10 sur sa
famille auxquels il a participé aux
côtés de didier bourdon ou encore de
marie anne chazel histoire parle du
cancer deux compères et des nombreuses
différences qui les a parfois séparés et
scénariste a pris tout de même quelques
libertés avec la réalité tue sa corsa tu
viens un pari plutôt réussi pour
l'humoriste qui est parvenu à rassembler
4,26 millions téléspectateurs pour une
part de marché de 21% ben c'est pas fait
exprès pourtant malgré la confiance que
tf1 lui accordent sur de nombreux
projets le succès de cette série au
lendemain de sa diffusion jarry après
les décisions de quitter la chaîne pour
au loin de france 2 alors malgré le
succès de la fiction à tes côtés jarry
qui tf1 pour france 2 choqué
que j'arrive n'a pas de contrat
qu'est-ce que vous êtes choqués oui oui
non non non non non ouais je pense que
c'est honnêtement je pense que c'est un
c'est un non événement mais c'est un
événement qui limite suis contente je
suis content pour lui je l'avais pas vue
venir vraiment je pense que l'inélégance
peut-être de sa part c'est d'avoir de
l'avoir dit hollande ou redescendre sur
terre s'il ya un petit truc qu'on ne
saurait lui reprocher tu as fait 4
millions la veille tf1 il y en a quand
même donné une visibilité qui arriveront
exactement oui aux alentours de noël il
a une autre fiction sur tf1 on va le
voir également comment ça dans mac
singer et puisque ça déjeuner et surtout
la grande chance qu'il a c'est qu'il a
encore la confiance des patrons tessin
qui lui ont dit si ça se passe pas bien
sur france 2 tu reviens quand tu vas à
la maison des associations
le côté très chic de la france l'a pas
retenu pour autant oui
s'il n'avait pas les moyens et en même
temps même si c'est très bien le job il
n'y a pas cassé la baraque avec ces
derniers formats c'est l'idéal car
c'était correct a jamais de l'armé d'un
contrat je ne pense pas moi je pense
qu'un bon j'en ai eus je pense qu'il
fait une grosse erreur parce que quand
on voit que jean marc généreux et bon
coup line et son parti n'ont rien fait
si on reste dans les placards il va
finir par s
amedi aiguille oui mais benjamines i
elle a dit
qu'elle avait des trucs
est-ce qu'on sait si c'est la france 2
déjà alors à ce qu on sait pas trop mais
ce qui semblerait si j'en ai obtenu ses
productions en fiction et du
divertissement et un rôle récurrent dans
de la fiction c'est ce qu'il voulait en
fait un rôle récurrent soit dedans de
serial killer ou quoi mais il aura un
rôle récurrent
autrement je trouve que franchement
jarry moi j'étais pas du tout fan de lui
ni dans vaitape ni en tant qu'humoriste
ni en tant qu'animateur et là je trouve
que les braqueurs pour le coup d'arrêt
la basse et tout
paraissait même heure oui c'est moi
j'aime bien meilleur sur scène et acteur
je suis franchement comme animateur d'un
jeu
ses confrères juste avant il n'a pas le
profil de l'animateur mais plutôt d'un
d'un meneur de revue d'un monsieur loyal
et comme tout français y en a mais c'est
que le spectacle ça mais dans deux
revues
bas est arrivé maintenant là
à part au lido je pense que
excuse moi c'était kevin oui et non je
trouve un peu sévère parce que fram
rappelé rappeler que sur tf1 les
programmes que j'arrivais à nîmes et
c'était que des formats qu'il avait
aucune liberté je sais que france 2 là
mon avis ils ont un coup à jouer c'est
qu'il prépare effectivement des
divertissements des programmes autour de
jarry qu'aujourd'hui un personnage on
qui vont profiter de ses talents
d'humoriste deux parce que c'est un
personnage ça m'étonne donc ils vont
vraiment usé de son talent en même temps
de cette fiction donc je pense qu'il
ailleurs une révélation de sur ça et que
s'il était resté plus longtemps sur tech
ans je pense qu'il allait droit dans le
mur et qui se serait flinguer pour le
reste de sa carrière d'abord voilà un
toit ils avancent bien